The simplest type of vector
arithmetic in R is just adding
the number to a vector.
Let's create a vector
v of values 10, 20,
30, 40, 50, and 60.
Then we'll add 1
to this vector.
When we add a single number to
a vector, it adds that number
to each element of the vector.
We can also do simple
multiplication, which works in
the same way.
Things get a little trickier
when you multiply two vectors,
where each are longer
than length 1.
Let's create a second vector
called w that takes values 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, and 7.
I've constructed this vector
using a special notation of
2:7, which generates
a sequence of
integers 2 through 7.
This is a handy way to create
a sequence of all integers
between two values.
Let's multiply v and w.
Is that what you expected?
R performs element-wise
vector multiplication.
That is, it'll take the first
value in each vector and
multiply them.
Then it'll take the second value
from each vector and
multiply those, and so on.
When working with vectors, R
works in the same way when
doing addition, subtraction,
division, and other basic
operations.
Things get a little more
confusing when we multiply
vectors of different lengths.
Let's overwrite w with a vector
of length 2 that takes
values 5 and 10.
When we multiply v and w now,
the result might be
surprising.
We get another vector
with six elements.
Let's take a closer look
at what happened.
The first two values
make sense.
They are, again, the
element-wise multiplication.
However, when we get to the
third value, it appears to be
the product of the third value
of v and the first value of w.
The fourth value is the product
of the last value of v
and the second value of w.
What we've just observed is that
are R recycled the vector
w so that it could complete the
multiplication across the
full length of v. It
also did so without
any warning or error.
R is built to recycle vectors,
and it doesn't always tell you
when it does so.
Let's do one more vector
multiplication.
Well, overwrite w one more time
and make it a vector of
length 4 with values
5, 10, 15, and 20.
Here this vector has
been created using
the sequence function.
The first argument says where
the sequence starts, the
second where the sequence should
end, and the third, how
big of jumps to take
to get from the
first to the last value.
Here again, we multiply
out v and w.
R again will recycle
w, but this time
it gives us a warning.
In this case, when R recycled w,
it still had elements left
over when it ran out of the
elements with v, so it wanted
to make sure that we
are aware of this.
There are several ways
we can perform
arithmetic in R using vectors.
We can raise every element in
a vector to a power or a
different power for
each element.
Here I have again used the
integer colon integer notation
to create a vector of values
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Many functions also work nicely
across vectors, such as
the square root function.
In the next video, we'll
learn about matrices.